sorry sorry would you would you submit
to a man if so what does your submission
cost there's a better way to phrase it
for me I would say it doesn't
it doesn't speak into the mic oh it
doesn't cost
um a particular amount he doesn't have
to make a particular amount I just think
what's important is that he's working
and for me I have a child as well so for
me
I mean
not initially I mean initially he
wouldn't necessarily be involved with my
son and everything but just to see that
he's able to have a good relationship
with children and things of that nature
that is
important to me because someone anyone
that I'm going to be with well
that I'm with
um it's important that they have a
relationship with my childhood so as
long as you're working it doesn't cost
so you have to if he's making 15 000
pounds a year
okay
um
I don't think it's
you would submit he can make all the
decisions in the household so like at
some point there's a number right we're
not we're not dating homeless man yeah
yeah at least I'm not I mean I don't
know
But but so we're about what about 25
000 that's the average median income
is this for everyone is this it says the
median average salaries for work all
workers in the UK is 25 000 pounds what
okay what you can be honest what job
title okay if okay
for me
it's a no it's a no no
that that wouldn't sustain much and
what job would you be having at I'm 28
so anyone that I would be with has to be
around my age or higher so what job are
you working that you're only receiving a
salary of 25 Grand that's not gonna cut
it so no no higher than 35
yeah that that would do 30 so your
submission costs your submission costs
roughly 35. around yeah roughly okay I
have I think I would have to agree as
well because in terms of like you were
talking about your daughter I have a
sister who's got something a son yeah
yeah yeah I have a sister that's got
autism so there's a lot of difficulties
with that and I have health issues
myself so it's like
you know like I would want someone more
about you know who could actually deal
with those things and be there in those
difficult times because I know not a lot
of people
will be willing to be part of that so
but in terms of your question it would
have to be that plus what you just said
which would be 35. well I mean if he's
barely working you know he'd have a lot
of time to support you
if anything like like that's better for
you right no no no so roughly 35 yeah
okay and and with that you would let him
make all the decisions in the household
like financially all your money's his
money he makes all the decisions
you don't think that's part of
submission no it's relinquishing control
yeah I think actually I mean I think it
depends on the man himself I don't think
every man wants to be in control of
every penny that comes into the
household but
yeah you can make majority of the
decisions but
I think well yeah I think we can make
sure I'm gonna actually I'm gonna do the
definition of submission just so I
probably should have started with that
the action of accepting or yielding to a
superior force or to the will or
authority of another person
so like it would be what he says goes
essentially I
um 35 000 a year
everything I don't I don't I don't think
any I don't think most men want to
control everything there what I don't
think most men want to control
everything you're also not answering the
question
so so like submission is relinquishing
control and that's part of femininity
yes that's that's submission it's it's
if you're okay so if you work for a boss
right like you they get to they say what
you do yeah they say how much you're
paid yeah so that that's submission you
submit to your boss that person is
authority over you yeah and so you can
pick which boss you want to work for
yeah but at the end of the day you're
relinquishing control that's part of
submission for me it depends with the
situation if you're earning 35
um preferably if you're a student like I
don't know your medical student or a PO
or something then that makes sense
during the dating phase but if I know
okay fine by the time we get married or
while you're studying then you're
earning more fine but it's not really
Financial the other like intangible
things that I would
be looking at for me to submit to you
that's about it so I'm not talking about
because that's a lot of times like The
Mating strategy girls do we'll get them
young and we'll try to build him up no
no this is an average guy
no this is this is this is this is he's
earning today this is what he's gonna
earn tomorrow
forever because most those people are
average you have to be tactful though
that's the way you have to be tactful
well I mean I think you guys are
misreading this uh you you hung up on
the 35 35 was like the the next level up
from the 25 what I think Pearl is trying
to ask is what would be the amount the
monetary amount that he could earn that
you would be like I'm talking when when
I mean I don't know if that's what you
mean but when I'm talking submission I'm
talking Middle Eastern submission
he is literally you come home she's
there with the slippers in her hand and
and she's on the table hello sir how are
you my dog so he says he says quit your
job you say when yes okay no questions
just like maybe over 50 just then
over 50 over 50. but it depends with
your age as well no no no no remember
he's not this isn't Building Man
no no no no no no no no no
this is what he earns today this is what
he's gonna earn tomorrow I think 50 is
like a reasonable number okay 50 000
pounds yeah I think I would say 50 then
yeah yeah if you're going complete okay
submission
um I would say like 70 and Beyond 70 000
pounds that would be enough to withhold
the life that and and do you guys
genuinely think you could at that
relinquish all control yeah I mean if
I'm earning 50 he's earning 50 we're
earning 100K yeah you could live
comfortably okay so yeah
sorry yeah do you think at that at 50
you could relinquish all control your
money's his money do you think that's
possible for you here's money is our
money my money is our money yes yeah
yeah okay but he makes the decisions on
it that's fine yeah okay okay cool
I'm very
the thing is like I'm not sure if I want
to get married so it's a different topic
in itself but if we're talking
hypothetically if it was like you know
this is a decision you have to make
yeah I'll probably have to go higher
okay 100 60.
70. no I just want to know what the
number is yeah maybe 17. for me to like
completely because otherwise yeah I
don't think I could okay that's the
starting yeah okay so I have a question
for the men do you think it's fair for
women to require a certain income for
them to come do you think it's fair for
women to require a certain income for
them to submit
it's not really about fairness it's just
that the way it is it is an exchange of
security and commodity for love and and
child
um I mean it is kind of I don't want to
make it out to be like I mean I know
Disney wants to make you believe that
you know love and all that starry-eyed
stuff can happen but in reality most
people are looking at you know what am I
giving up going into this and what am I
getting in return that's why I brought
up the dowry